Tori's found a niche her prices are very
very good you know she's not at that
high level designer price point she just
isn't up there with you know a four
thousand dollar dress or a two and a
half thousand dollar jacket she's she's
in a lower price point which I think
allows her to have more popularity with
more a larger audience and I think that
was a very smart decision she's also
capitalized I think she's got a kind of
preppy sort of prepping us with an edge
is how I consider Tori it's it's kind of
classic conservative on one level yet
she breaks out either the prints are a
little bit bolder or the colors are a
little bit more cutting-edge so she's
got a bit of nuance and a bit of style
but based on him a more classic genre
however it's not tedious it's not preppy
it's not Lilly Pulitzer definitely
something bigger and and and more
interesting than that and again at a
great price point
I do I i think you know Diane von
Furstenberg you know one of the joy ends
of American fashion and certainly a
fixture of New York fashion and head of
the CFDA now you know one of Diane's
great successes is again her price
points are reasonable they're just
underneath that designer price point so
she allows people to have access to
fashion to her brand the way Tory does
but at much more affordable prices and I
think so you know Alber Elbaz for lava
is now doing a great t-shirt line he's
going to be doing a line of kind of lava
classics those are going to be at less
prices I think all of the designers are
looking at price they're looking at how
to bring more value to the customer as
well as keeping the customer excited and
wanting to buy so while they're doing
color texture fun prints getting
everyone's eye popping as they get into
a retail space they're also having the
price tags come down a bit and I think
it's a big trend and they're all
thinking about it
I love it I love the high-low I think
you know when Karl Lagerfeld infamously
of his own line and obviously of Chanel
came and did hmm you know he just
becomes for him it's such a brand
extension he becomes a kind of iconic
person you know it sort of Carl like
Anna Wintour it's Anna and it's Carl so
I think it's very smart from their point
of view I think it's great that the
great you know the masses can touch a
bit of designer merchandise I mean I
went to H&M and bought one of Carl's
sequin jackets and have it in my closet
is just kind of an archival piece I love
that they do that high-low thing I'm I
don't stay in their ivory tower with
their you know $20,000 couture dresses
you know I think luxury brands are you
know there's been a real reset button
going on it was a big piece that we
discussed in the New York Times
yesterday discussing a luxury brands in
Japan have really taken a dive you know
the Japanese used to consider buying a
Louis Vuitton bag a kind of rite of
passage they would sacrifice ranch and
food to be able to do that and that's
that generation is no longer than
generation of now who is more interested
in vintage things slightly more eclectic
design so I think luxury brands are used
to having an ongoing meteor rock
meteoric rise that they no longer can
sustain and they're going to have to
readjust all that to say I think the
world's had to readjust I think we've
all had to readjust personally
professionally for sure in the Great
Recession all that to say I think some
of the key classic brands like Louise we
talk like a Chanel like an hermès those
tried-and-true strapless brands those
have a quality that is without sounding
like a cliche really timeless and to buy
a louis vuitton bag will always be that
to get a Chanel suit will always be that
to have something from Hermes again it
will always be there forever and I think
that's where people are going to buy
investment pieces they're going to go
back to the recognized classics that
will have value even if it's something
that's what you it's going to be an
heirloom for your child even if it's
something that you know that if you need
to you could sell it on ebay or that's
something that's not going to fall apart
because you know the quality of a VTOL
chanel of an hermes has an enduring
longevity it's going to not fall apart
in three years the way some things do so
I think those guys those houses will be
fun and we'll be even smarter in the way
they edit and and and make their
collections you know are the days of
people buying nine handbags the season
over absolutely will they come back in
my opinion no is everyone gonna have to
readjust that for sure I think the
things that again are true and real and
have quality and integrity will stay and
sustained I think the things that are
false that designers that really don't
have talent that really aren't focused
that really don't have the calling
workmanship you know the consumers too
smart her dollars are too precious or
his dollars or two to two precious and
they're really looking at things as well
as price tag and they're going to be
making very very strict decisions on
where they put their dollars so I think
it's a real readjustment for everybody
in a necessary one I think we've gone
into a slightly crazy consumer you know
yeah
you know and I wouldn't call it a big
change i think maybe there was an
occasional girl here or there that's a
little bit more eclectic looking a
little different there's a big big star
out of Europe colora stone you know
she's quite full chested she's got the
crazy big gap in her teeth you know
she's not a size zero she's kind of an
it model girl at the moment but she
stands out because of other things she's
got almost a kind of actress appeal to
her I don't think unfortunately we're
going back to kind of normal sizes where
size six is the norm the way it was you
know 25 30 years ago girls are still
very very tall they're still I think
overly skinny the samples you know it's
difficult a lot of the celebrities can't
even wear the samples because they're so
small because these girls are so tiny
I'd like to say it was a change that we
are going back to a slight sense of
normalcy in the way because I do think
it's a problem and it's been talked
about certainly in the last several
years in fashion about what to do about
it but I don't think fashions ready for
that I don't think the designers are
ready for it nor the model agency so I'm
afraid we're still in status quo mode
to break it down models are kind of
hangers you know they've got good
shoulders and then the clothing drapes
off them and it without it sounding
calculating and dry there there's
something easier about designing when
the fit is not anything you have to
reconsider or consider and if you've got
you know a beautiful long neck a tall
stature and a great shoulders you know
the clothing just it hangs the French
have a great expression for that there
she's a bottom Aldo she's a hanger and
that that's that's just an easier way to
get your idea of fashion across when
you're not competing with waist chest
hip shortness of leg when you're not
dealing with any kind of other physical
issues you can really go for the design
that you want to do in its purest form
so that i think is indeed at the end of
the day why the designers choose it
I think you know when Coco Chanel took
the corset and threw it out the window
and unbound everything and gave a loose
jacket gave women pants gave women
oversized gave women nets and Jersey I
mean those we're not a part of
vernacular they were wearing bustles and
corsets so Coco as a you know the first
one of the first great liberating female
designers can't really count Elsa
Schiaparelli because she was part of the
whole da da and you know art scene so
their contribution was marvelous but
clearly different yes I think it's very
empowering I think there's choice out
there I think they're set fashion is
such a big business now there's so many
choices for women you can really each
season find what you like if you don't
like the 80s you can do the 40s that's
kind of you know nipped in waist a
shoulder pad you can go for a more
conservative look you don't have to go
for sequin leggings and a big crazy you
know brocade top from Gucci you can go
too much more quiet lava asked for the
version of that which is the 40s so yes
I think there's great choice for women
and I think women more and more have
more confidence to where would they want
where how they want to do it and you
know not be constrained even by what we
fashion journalist tell them is in in
what school I think that's that's what's
really nice and I think the other thing
you know I was chatting with with with
Marc Jacobs the other day you know he
can't stand it when people wear his
clothes had to tell me he likes it when
you mix it all up and you buy one of his
pieces and and and where it was
something else i was talking to another
designer said i love when you rediscover
things in your closet i think it's
really great you've gone back in and
found a great jacket ground found a
great blouse you mix it all in so i
think women are more empowered i think
they're allowed to be sexier if they
want to be stronger if they want to be
and the choices are really out there all
price points and actually you know you
can almost find what you want each
season at every season so that's that's
a lovely a lovely amount of choice that
women now
you